I have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine to david p here's a
voicemail i received yesterday or early
this morning about the vice presidential
debate between tim kaine and mike pence
david i was watching the debate last
night and i don't really understand why
the media keep saying that night pence
won the debate now am I missing
something it seemed like Mike Pence's
lining in lying the entire time palaces
a winning strategy yeah I mean we as we
mentioned a out here as we mentioned the
optics word that pence was presented if
physically in a way that that seemed
more confident than tim kaine and if you
will if you don't know that pence is
just lying through his teeth the entire
time i could see how you come away
thinking on optics pence one but yeah we
did our analysis and clearly pence got
clobbered didn't defend basically a
single position of Donald Trump's on the
bonus show today NFL television ratings
keep dropping is this at all connected
to the concussion crisis we will discuss
that and also we will talk about an
effort to stop weighted wasting food
partially partially by cutting back on
portion size those stories and more on
today's bonus show remember there is
only one way to sign up for the bonus
show become a member and get instant
access to all of these great member
benefits and it happens to be by going
to david pakman.com slash membership if
you want because today was a hey treat
male day you can use coupon code hey
tree at 40 that's h80 our iot 40 to get
a nice discount off of your membership
sign up today we'll talk to you on the
bonus show